Se nos dice que: "Juana está haciendo crepas con
harina, huevos y leche. Esta tabla proporciona
el costo por kilogramo de cada ingrediente y la
cantidad en kilogramos que usa Juana. La cantidad
total que Juana gasta en ingredientes es de 6
dólares. Escribe una ecuación que relacione a,
b, c y d". Pausa este video y trata de resolverlo.
Muy bien, ahora vamos a resolver esto juntos. Me
gusta hacer esto en tiempo real para que puedan
ver mi proceso de pensamiento, así que voy a
resolver esto junto contigo. Entonces, veamos. El
total que gasta Juana, que incluye harina, huevo
y leche, es de 6 dólares, entonces, una forma de
pensar en esto es -y lo escribiré en diferentes
colores-, los dólares de harina, más los dólares
de huevo o la cantidad que Juana gasta en huevos,
más la cantidad que Juana gasta en leche o los
dólares de leche, serán iguales a la cantidad
total, serán iguales a 6 dólares. ¿Y cuál es la
cantidad total que Juana gasta en harina? Bueno,
por aquí nos dicen que son 0.9 dólares por
kilogramo multiplicado por a kilogramos,
entonces Juana va a gastar 0.9 a dólares; sólo
voy a multiplicar estas dos cosas para calcular
cuánto gasta Juana en harina. Entonces esto
será igual a -y ya no pondré el símbolo de
dinero para poder concentrarnos en los números
y las variables- 0.9 a, y esto por supuesto va
a estar en dólares, lo cual es importante.
Voy a sumar dólares más dólares más dólares
para obtener dólares. ¿Y qué hay con respecto
a los huevos? Bueno, aplicamos la misma idea:
0.2 kilogramos por b dólares por kilogramo, si
tomo el producto de estos dos obtendré 0.2 b
dólares, o sólo 0.2 b si no escribo el símbolo de
dinero. Y por último, pero no menos importante,
la leche. Permíteme hacer el producto de estas dos
cosas, de esto y de esto; entonces d kilogramos a
c dólares por kilogramo, esto sólo va a ser
c por d dólares, así que sumamos cd y todo
esto será igual a 6 dólares. Y hemos terminado,
escribimos una ecuación que relaciona a, b, c y d.